so now watch what happens when we say
this remember this is not a result that
I can just quote so I'm going to derive
it it will only take me like two two and
a half lines I'm gonna use this is my
tool to answer the same question
okay can you ready here we go so if you
want it by the way what you just did
this is the UM this is the Cartesian
approach okay everything's in terms of
X's and Y's and I've no parameters
anywhere in sight what I'm about to do
is the parametric approach okay first
thing I'm going to do is on this is what
I'm going to get to in a second okay to
use a parameter to the perimeter I need
stuff in x squared equals 4a y4 that's
part of the reason why we introduce that
form in the first place so x squared
equals 12 Y so I'm just gonna rewrite
that as x squared equals four what's my
a it'll be three there it is this the
focal length BAM it just pulls out okay
I'm going to need that in a moment
when I use my equation of a tangent
right intelligent phone cuz there's the
focal length I need the focal or form
it's not hot
ace three basic 43 so what am I gonna do
with that okay well if a is equal to 3
then every point on this parabola P is
in the same form H 3 we usually say to
AP AP squared don't we that's what we
normally say but I know what a is
so what form I'm gonna be is 16 3p
squared
nailed it okay so now I know what the
coordinate point is it's very very easy
to get to the equation of a tangent
right the equation of the tangent will
be I'm gonna use point gradient form
there's my point 3p squared
what's my gradient at P it's just P
that's that's the parameter right that's
the whole reason why we use it
and he's my ex - 6p okay
now we already know in advance where
this is going to go see this is a
tremendous advantage of having this in
your back pocket I'm just going to go
straight in it okay I don't need to [ __ ]
around from here to here I think it's
pretty good
now how am I going to use this little
party well remember this is not just a
particular tension this is every single
tangent on the entire parabola
you remember how here I had every single
Y that goes through that point so what I
have now got a kid it's not every single
life from that point I have raaaah
every single tangent everywhere for
every single point on the curve for
different values of people okay now
which of the tangents that I want the
tangents that I want are the two
tangents that particularly go through
this one point that I'm after right
where's that point two minus one there
is down there okay so if these two
tensions that I want go through there
then I should be able to just pop them
in right and it'll satisfy the equation
there's my - and there's my minus one
and you just satisfied with that now
it's got this is easy as pie to deal
with right 3p squared minus 2p minus 1
just making it a nice quadratic now if
you solved now this right and you went
all the way down you screwed it at some
point
written 3m squared minus 2m minus 1
equals zero and then you would have
factorized and gotten these why are we
getting the same quadratic we're getting
the same quadratic because we're solving
the same question from a different angle
right here it was which gradient do you
want right which gradient one up here
the question is which which tangent do
you want but the tangent and the
gradient
saying right so when you solve this
unsurprisingly
P is minus 1 over 3 or 1 once you
factorize them okay and you take these
guys and you put them back into when I
write it here is this is the equation of
every single tangent and as a bonus this
is already in MX plus B form whereas the
other one wasn't it to do some
rearrangement I'm still going to get
this out okay now you remember I said I
skipped like 2/3 of the working PR on
this proof I didn't skip anything here
right it's all there and in terms of the
concepts I needed I didn't leave the
discriminant an engine work worried
about solving simultaneously I just went
with using the parameter because this is
a question about parameters it's about
the gradients that you want right so
that's how you know it's the right kind
of tool to use what's the question
interested in use the form that leads
you most naturally towards what's asking